c'est drôle ça je m'oto tête de turquise
je me suis retrouvé en combinaison en
cuillère avec une boule dans la bouche
et tout moi c'est horrible ce que je
fais je vous chargerai je vous trouperai
et je vous
tuerai no fr bonjour Petit CAH dessin
j'aurais aimé que vous dessiniez l'un
l'autre et que vous montriez les dessins
à la fin de on se dessine l' l'autre
super idéès rigolo il dessine super bien
je pas faire les
[Musique]
caricatures
je suis sûr mais il y aura vengeance
c'est que dans le 1 si tu veux il y
avait une
erreur chirurgicale médicale où je me
suis retrouvé avec une poitrine de de
femme tu vois et j'avais je me
retrouvais avec 4 heur de maquillage
tous les jours mais c'était bien fait on
avait vraiment l'impression que j'avais
des des desessins quoi tu vois ouais
c'était vraiment bien fait ceétait
gênant c'est que je sentais que ça
excitait T pour de vrai et ça c'était
très très gênant et sur son premier film
épouse-moi mon pote je me suis retrouvé
en combinaison en cuir avec une boule
dans la bouche et tout franchement on
est trop gentil avec lui ton projet là
de nous faire dessiner c'est très rigolo
mais ça nous rend quand même très mal
poli parce qu'on te regarde pas ouais
c'est vrai mais mais mais j'assume parce
que c'est complètement de ma faute
[Musique]
d'accord c'est que moi j'écris les films
que Fifi réalise donc je m'uto tête de
turquise mais mais après sur les films
de Tarek c'est vrai que là j'ai pris un
peu cher quand même mais on s'est bien
marré quand même je il y a plein de
trucs tu sais ce qu' m'a fait à un
moment je tombe dans une espèce de
flaque debout et on était dans une
grotte et il me dit je lu dis mais tu es
sûr que c'est propre et tout ça parce
que j'y vais vraiment franchement et il
me dit oui oui t'inquiète pas c'est du
terreau qu'on a été chercher chez un
jardinier et tout donc on tourne le truc
j'y vais franchement il me refait faire
plein de fois le truc j'y retourne j
retourne et à 2 jours après il me dit en
fait c'était pas du tout du Terrero
parce que ce qu'on avait ramené ça
faisait pas naturel donc on a pris la
boue de la grotte dans laquelle les
chauves-souris chillaient chiait et donc
je me suis retrouvé avec ça sur la tête
pendant toute une journée sans savoir ce
que
[Musique]
c'était et ça sert à rien de vous cacher
je vous a reconnu tuav g euh jamais
jamais une fois avec auarsy et
mon bah moi là l'autre jour il y a un
gars il vient me voir me fait ah j'aime
beaucoup ce que vous faites et tout du
coup tu sais tu es toujours touché je ah
merci et tout vraiment je vous trouve
drôle et tout oh merci à la radio et
tout donc là je commence à bugger parce
que je pas de radio me fait et a me dit
allez salut Cartman bon ben salut Je pas
désamorcerman ça va ouais quand on éta
jeun on disait à Julen qui ressemblait à
PEF mais en moche ouais moi c'est
horrible ce que je
fais dans la vie ah il fait des super
peintures c'est génial je pense qu'à sa
mort ça va prendre une valeur folle
ouais ouais ouais bah nous nous les
films d'action de l'époque Bruce
williser
Stalone Tom Cruise il avait pas encore
pris le créneau de l'action à l'époque
il l'a pris après mais là c'est vrai que
c'est plus des références au films
d'action un peu plus moderne quoi les
les fast and ferous les
missionsossibles tout ça mais ah c que
il y a aussi des petits clin d'œil à Bel
mondo il y a de tout il y a de tout tu
as vu la référence à
Emmanuel le blanc de
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouf oui ouais lui il était fan de bah
c'est ses films préférés Seven et donc
il nous refaisait s la scène de fin avec
BR pit qui était comme ça non non si
tuinistes il peux te le refire non non
là je l'ai plus là tu du dialogue si si
son sans arrêt MS pose ton arm MS MS non
non c'est ça voilà chez moi remé
Juliette aussi quand tu as d Caprio il
tombait par terre comme çais il saignait
dit non il avait tué tbalt ah ouais
ouais tibag non
c'est star d'action to serais r Freddy
ouais et moi une star de film d' ouais
non Tom Cruise ouais Tom cru pour moi
c'est pas Tom Cruise le plus grand
cascadeur même si c'est incroyable ce
qu'il fait pour moi c'est Jackie Chan ah
ouais c'est le gars lui il estimattable
il est fou sur mais a joué avec Tom
Cruise tellement fan de Tom Cruise le
mec il a tout il a tout il a tout fait
et dans tu vois la carrière de Tom cru
elle est juste exceptionnelle c'estàd
qu'il a fait des films tellement
tellement variés dans tous les genres et
une longévité de carrière enfinà c'est
fou non moi j' moi il est mort celui
mais c'était Michel Galabru ah ouais
faisait des cascades exceptionnelles
avec lui de
[Musique]
funesse je crois pas que ce soit un
complexe je crois que c'est une envie
c'est Enie ouais ouais ouais il a très
envie de de de faire ses cascades alors
du coup Tom Cruise en ce moment il la
référence il y a quelques années c'était
plutôt Jean-Paul belmondeo et et du coup
il a fait plusieurs références au à
différents films et de Tom Cruise et de
Jean-Paul Belmondo mais c'est quelque
chose qu'il adore faire en fait il adore
l'adrénaline t il a pas quand on a fait
bi Sting 2 on faisait on a dû
s'entraîner pour faire des soins en
parachute bah sur les premiers saut
c'était le seul de nous trois qui avait
pas peur nous on était terrifié et lui
non non non c'est cool et tout et il
aime ça en fait ça fait partie de lui le
côté adrénaline donc le fait de se
dépasser en faisant ses ses ses cascades
bah c'est une espèce de continuité de
voilà des fois on a un petit peu peur
pour lui mais je tiens à dire que nous
aussi quand même on a fait des cas des
sacr cascad voilà à un moment on emballe
des meufs et on l'a fait nous-même ouais
pas de doubleur et en plus c'est légal
parce qu'on est payé pour ça ouais après
le piège c'est que des fois il croit que
les filles ont le Bégin pour lui sauf
que elles sont payé aussi
peut-être qu' elles étaient tombées un
[Musique]
peu fr ah ouais on aim beaucoup Franck
mais évidemment non non Franck moi
j'adore enfin on adore ce qu'il fait et
c'est très cool c'est vrai qu' il vient
faire une petite surprise dans le film
et je trouvais ça très chouette de sa
part salut on est sur le tournage de 3
jours max aujourd'hui on a la grande
chance d'avoir le grand Franck
Gastambide je suis très content d'être
là mais aussi sa doublure
lumière merci d'être là a c'est bien
l'ambiance c'est bien entre
vous écoute babyting 3 c'est qu'on nous
le demande énormément c'est pas qu'on
veut pas c'est on trouve pas la bonne
idée si tu veux ce qui serait terrible
pour nous c'est de faire un numéro 3 où
tout le monde dis c'est pas bien tu vois
qui déçoiv donc jour on revient avec ça
on veut vraiment avoir la la bonne idée
quoi qu'on trouve le le bon truc on l'a
pas
encore
commence non il pas bien moi je pense
que je t'
BTU vas-y vas-y c'est pas ouf vasy
montre je avou c'est pas ouf c'est pas
nul ah ouais c'est pas nul vous savez ce
que c'est ça cicatrice là il a fait
croire à tout le monde que c'était une
BAGAR et tout en vérité c'est les forces
ne rattra ESS pas de rattraper la
médiocrité mon dessin il est pas
ouf ah ouais il est mieux ah il est
bien ferme les
yeux jusqu'à la chemise et tout jusqu'au
détail de la chemise ah oua il est merci
beaucoup ah ben merci beaucoup
franchement merci à vous de vous être
prêté au jeu là c'est bien
[Musique]
cool